Speaker 1: Let's talk about solutions, so-called
to the gun violence problem.
I'm going to play a clip for you here of the
last roughly 24 hours of Fox News and the
roughly 50 solutions that they have proposed
to the issue of gun violence.
It might not come as a surprise that none
of the solutions relate to gun safety.
Okay.
Let's just take a listen and see if you can
find the trend here.
I'll give you a hint.
It's none of these things have to do with
guns.
Unless you mean giving more people guns.
Speaker 3: I advocate always for an armed
security guard, armed school safety officer,
armed deputy.
Arming teachers, potentially arm and prepare
and train teachers and other administrators.
Armed school staffers bring in policemen.
Speaker 4: Training.
Speaker 3: The students themselves.
Retired military, retired law enforcement.
We can offer them tax breaks.
If you give law enforcement the opportunity
to impose martial law, we can get safety and
security.
Securing that perimeter kind of providing
kind of a ring of steel.
You have the fences, you have the administration
building, and then you have wide gaps on either
side.
The fencing is not very high.
Speaker 2: Where the doors locked, bulletproof
glass.
All of these shootings have happened at the
same time that we see religion and Christian
values.
Speaker 1: And that's another one it's got
the problem isn't guns.
The problem is lack of God.
Speaker 2: Judeo-Christian values declining.
Speaker 3: Anybody who decides that they want
to do something like this should immediately
know that attacking a school is a death sentence
for them.
Kids are afraid of being the school snitch.
Speaker 2: We have to stop letting these schools
be gun free zones.
Speaker 3: People need to put their phones
down and get to know the person next to them.
Speaker 2: We have spent billions of dollars
on COVID related measures for our schools.
Let's take some of that money and divert it
over to hard hitting these soft targets.
A lot.
Speaker 3: Of these private schools, they
take security way more serious.
Speaker 2: Parents take your children to church.
This anti-police narrative is forcing people.
Speaker 3: Not to call police a series of
interlocking doors at the school entrance
that are triggered.
Speaker 1: By the way, how absurd people are
not calling the police.
The police were on the scene 40 to 60 Minutes
while the shooter was rampaging in the classroom.
Speaker 3: And tripwire and it traps the shooter
like a rat.
Speaker 2: God is the answer to that.
There's a moral rot going on that we all need
to dig in and try to address.
Speaker 3: I vote for decreasing social media
exposure.
We need to start focusing on mental health.
Tell us why you think it's important to pray
in a moment like this.
Speaker 2: Calls for faith and prayer.
Why is it that schools are protected in the
same way that airports are?
Some people who don't want a police officers
in schools with guns because other people
are triggered.
Speaker 1: Assault rifle triggering is the
people being triggered is the problem.
Speaker 3: It's body armor but notification
system to what everybody in the school know
what's happening?
Single point of entry.
I don't like talking about this stuff as it
happens because I don't think it contributes
anything positive.
Parents should be held accountable for raising
their children properly.
Ballistic blankets.
We just don't have the resources to get law
enforcement there.
Quickly, how about an executive order for
these?
Mental health facilities.
Speaker 2: We have to start rebuilding this
country and returning to God.
Speaker 3: I arm myself everywhere I legally
can.
It's up to you to protect yourself.
Hmm.
Speaker 1: Wow.
Oh, boy.
Guys, that we are.
We are screwed as a country.
Dear God.
By the way, you know, a couple of those suggestions.
Ballistic blankets and armor plated backpacks
for kids, the very same people who for two
years have been saying, oh, if you make kids
wear masks in schools, the psychological effect
of that is going to destroy them.
Now they're saying, let's send children to
school with ballistic blankets and bulletproof
backpacks to be taught by armed teachers in
a school surrounded by tripwire with prison
like fences and airport security.
Come on, guys.
This is this is absolutely absurd.
And I want to focus next on this issue of
doors.
Now they're blaming doors.